[Music]
TJ sociable laughed when you said Yogi
Bear 3ds so that's why you did you
actually like know either man's life I
did not I didn't laugh
I really sold it and then and II laughed
and I was appalled I was horrified by
his reaction yogi berra 3d makes people
happy I like that it has the the 3d in
the title
that's so you really know what it is
which is the greatest piece of talking
bear comedy that's ever really I I
consider myself the premier talking bear
comedian in the United States there's
one there's one in Canada but he sucks
yeah so you think that yogi berra 3d has
puts you on the map in terms of
comedians being in talking bear films
Conan it's difficult to reach the
pinnacle of your career as a comedic
actor early on and so that was for me
Yogi Bear 3d and then you know from then
on out it's just been sort of a plateau
that's gonna probably let crash land you
know oppressing speech I've ever heard
like if you're wearing a tuxedo jacket
are you I am and I'm wearing just
regular suit pants and then these these
socks were given to me by my wife my
fianc and wait fiance well yeah I
calling my wife because I don't know how
to prance
no no pianos try intended yeah knightly
trove ed condolences now this is true
you did just get engaged not long ago
yeah I did when you tell us a story of
how you got engaged well I did it at the
Art Museum the Los Angeles County Museum
of Art and because she is a work of art
and what they don't tell you is that you
when you get down on your knee to
propose just don't do it so quickly you
know I just I went down fast and it
really hurt my knees it really did was
it concrete oh yeah it was concrete it
was under this rock that is a art piece
and in the museum which doesn't make any
sense they just put a rock up and then
you can walk under it and so right now
I'd been put between a rock and a hard
place so I I went I went down fast I
went down hard and I it hurt so much and
I sort of you know you have to hide that
because it's a really romantic moment so
I was like ah will you Kate will you or
will you make me the happiest guy and
but I got through it and and she said
yes which was really exciting was she
and say yes she said okay you know but
yeah and yeah so we're really really
excited as soon as you get engaged
the next thing everyone says well when's
the wedding day and then once you have a
wedding day you know they say well when
are you gonna have kids and once you
have kids they say it's all downhill
from here on out when are you going to
die
[Laughter]
you